es ist ja ein altes hausmittel
apfelessig ach das geht mit einem ass
ich nicht wie ist das mit einfach
domestos darüber müsste doch auch helfen
habe ja der eigengeschmack
[Musik]
wie wollen sie es schaffen unsere unsere
hohen lebensmittel standards zu halten
mit zb 88% multiresistenter keime auf
putenfleisch
hier wollen wir lieber bisher reduzieren
ja diese multiresistenten keime werden
wir offen lästige übergossen und
eingerieben noch eine minute verfügt der
stick geschmack und ist dann auch weg es
ist ja ein altes hausmittel nur apfel
ist ach das geht mit einem ass ich nicht
wie ist das mit einfach domestos darüber
müsste doch auch helfen aber der
rhythmus eigengeschmack usw
unsere kunden keine guten die guten
multiresistenten keimen fahre ich ja ich
finde es nicht gut dass geht darum der
bund hatte eine untersuchung gemacht im
letzten ende des letzten jahres
veröffentlicht das eben extrem viele
multiresistente keime auf putenfleisch
entdeckt wurden
alles fleisch was man beim
markendiscounter heute kaufen kann ist
das so oder ist das schlimm also kaymer
sind erstmal wirklich überall vorhanden
also wir haben es hier mit einem
naturprodukt zu tun und somit auch mit
keimen ja es ist aber die
massentierhaltung wohin die sowie tiere
ab so engen rahmen haben da müssen
lernen was gehen wir als es im fernsehen
dauernd alle kranken kindern solle
wegschmeißen
wenn sie an einer demo teilnehmen würden
für für den erhalt deutscher
lebensmittel standards denn wir sie mal
patriotische es dagegen die
amerikanisierung des abendbrot es kurz
pda mit pkw nichts zu tun mit tequila es
auch nicht so so klien und so glücklich
ist es wirklich das ist absolut live
glücklich ist ja sehr menschlich eine
sehr subjektive betrachtung wo wir das
jetzt als glücklich betrachten aber das
ist die ganz reale situation in einem
deutschen hähnchen statt
wie kommen dann die anlage immer dazu
das gegenteil zu berichten naja das ist
immer auch die herangehensweise wenn sie
natürlich nachts in einen stall
eindringen lassen sieht das anders aus
schwarzwälder schinken klar der muss aus
dem schwarzwald kommen
das verstehe ich aber warum muss
mindestens immer ein bundesminister aus
franken kommen
das ist auch gesetzlich geschützte hier
ganz angabe ja das sollte zum beispiel
auch das bier oder auch auf die wurst
weit ein deutsch sprechen ja sicher
jetzt andere länder einverstanden
natürlich führt auch deutsch sprechende
oder bayerisch oder franke die
hersteller der greußener salami haben
uns gebeten ob sie vielleicht ja für die
greußener salami stehen könnten zur
greußener salami stehen könnten und
bitte das in die in die kamera halten
greußener salami und ich habe noch ein
paar andere dinge die ich dann sagen
würde zum beispiel nürnberger lebkuchen
zum beispiel auch schwäbische spätzle
allgäuer emmentaler